oh hey maybe wandering with this badges
well I stole it off the web sheriff cuz
after they're in town apparently if you
guys didn't know the web sheriff is here
in YouTube town and they're on the prowl
on the prowl for copy written videos and
let me tell you how I know this because
they took down my seed Jobs Lady Gaga
parody
don't worry because I'm not really that
upset at all not no big deal
I didn't mean to
and hopefully sometimes in your future
when I actually meet that real web share
if I can apologize I'm sorry I'm sorry
web share for you is because I went to
copyright school I learned all the
things that I'm not supposed to do and
now I'm a student of a copyright
infringement of web sheriff school of
irony was fair use anyway if you haven't
seen the video here it is sped up really
really fast
and if you'd like to see that in normal
speed go ahead and check out my blog at
iJustine comm and you can see the full
thing there and I'm sorry I didn't take
you down the web sheriff they took it
down it was bad alright guys see you
later I'm off to copyright jail see you
guys on the flip side